for that though the agreement that was
reached on saturday
out of the blue between the new york
jets and the seattle seahawks they've
been recent trade partners
in the not too distant past but now
boom jamal adams wanting out of new york
getting out of new york getting to the
seattle seahawks
four two first round picks a third round
pick this year
safety bradley macdougald jamal adams
and a fourth round pick in 2022 make the
trek from new york to seattle
chris i was stunned that the jets were
able to get this kind of a haul
and this reminds me of the conversations
we had last october as it related to
jaylen ramsey
there are certain offers you cannot
refuse and
joe douglas the gm of the jets almost
used that exact quote from the godfather
they made us an offer we couldn't ignore
no they made you an offer you couldn't
refuse
i don't care how good jamal adams is two
ones
and a three and bradley mcdougall for
adams in a four
in 2022 you can't say no to that no
you can't say no to that you you can't
it's it's
it's beautiful especially when you know
a guy that you're looking to trade
doesn't want to be on your football team
anymore
so yeah i mean awesome for for the jets
yeah you got to take that deal certainly
when you know you got to pay a guy and
he's disgruntled
i also say awesome for the seattle
seahawks i mean
go for it seattle the time is now you
know you got russell wilson signed up
he's a super bowl winning quarterback
he's the type of quarterback that if you
can get into the final four
or the super bowl game the final two he
can make plays to win you that game even
though you might not be the better team
on the field that day
and a guy like jamal adams of course ups
the ante on the defensive side of the
ball and it's a really important
position for that defense mike
i think it's something they've been
missing and trying to find to replace
ever since cam chancellor hurt his neck
and that's the position he'll play
and i think that's why it's special you
know this is an important
derwen james drafted for the los angeles
chargers same defensive scheme
same position so now you got a guy jamal
adams
in seattle i think a team that's really
set up to kind of make a run for the
next four or five years
he's playing a key position and i love
cam chancellor
but he ain't as talented as jamal adams
is jamal adams mike
you you hear me out here this might be
you could make he's in the conversation
for
i think that second best defensive
player in football he really is for my
money you know aaron donald's won but i
think they're you know you go through
that long list of next guys i go man
jamal adams is in that
that long list there and you're right it
fits the scheme
look at who they deal with in the nfc
west currently the toughest division in
all of football
with the rams the 49ers and the
cardinals kyler murray is ascending
the 49ers are the 49ers and the rams
once they
stabilize after all the departures that
they've seen and if jared goff can turn
it around they're going to need defenses
that can slow them down
so i think from that perspective it
makes sense and something coach p
carroll told peter king for football
morning in america
the seahawks haven't drafted above
number 25 in round one in 10 years and
that's a point we make when questions
come up about franchise tag
players you know two first-round picks
is what you have to give up
to get a guy whose franchise tagged well
it's one thing
for a perennially crappy team to give up
two first-round picks
it's quite another for the patriots to
give up
two first-round picks and the seahawks
fall into that same category
there's a huge split between 1 and 32
and when you are traditionally
congregating near the bottom of the
round
two first-round picks don't have the
same sizzle
than it would if the browns
in past years the bengals in recent
years
sure the jaguars in most years right
would be giving up two first-round picks
right i totally agree i mean you know i
think anybody with a sensible mind
right here could sit here and just go
whether you like the seahawks or not go
oh yeah i don't think any of those picks
are going to be
anywhere before pick 22 in the draft and
i would say that's being kind for the
way that team's set up
and then i think it's a great point
either way you know with peter
with pete carroll and john schneider i
mean
these are guys that have showed us that
you know first round picks first off
they didn't build their team they built
their team on second third fourth fifth
round picks
i mean that's what they've done that's
why they've hung around here for the
last decade in a row
or last ten years in a row uh because of
their ability to track mid-rounds i know
same thing i just wanted to clear a
decade in a row i understand a decade
ago
one decade in a row is still technically
accurate i know i'm trying to force some
more
entries into sims isms but that doesn't
count no it doesn't count
but i i mean i so from that you know i
think when you just add it up from
seattle's standpoint and you go
wait russell wilson in his prime okay
we've kind of rebuilt our team here the
last few years to where
yeah it's not perfect but it's kind of
all culminating into
well we think we got something here to
be one of the better teams in football
for the next few years
and then you go all right bobby wagner's
getting a little older we drafted jordan
brooks in the first round on a texas
tech
okay we'll be able to replace him in the
next year or two and then
you know cam chancellor that was a
special guy a special part you have to
have a special skill set
to play that position you know uh again
think about what that guy is going to
have to do in that seattle defense right
mike you got to take on pulling guards
you got to you got to play like a
linebacker in the run game
and then in the past game all of a
sudden you got to be like oh no you need
to run with travis kelsey oh we need you
out of the backfield against alvin
kamara
and you got to do that too so it's a
really special skill set of a guy there
and jamal adams certainly can do that
and i think it's just a perfect fit as
far as system-wise and what seattle's
trying to do right now
and uh you know that's why i like the
trade from seattle standpoint a whole
lot
the one thing i do not like about the
trade from seattle's standpoint is the
failure to sign him to a new contract on
the way through the door
this is now a thing right in the nfl
when the texans did it with laramie
tunsil last year labor day weekend as
the rosters were moving down to 53.
we we all were like what what
and the jokes were plentiful because the
texans didn't have a gm at the time
but to give up multiple first round
picks for laramie tons of kenny stills
and you don't get a new deal with tunsil
on the way in the door
you give the player more leverage and
what did we see a three-year 66 million
dollar extension for tunsil
this year 22 million a year in new money
and then
the rams do the same thing with jaylen
ramsey yeah during
the season they don't get him signed to
a new deal they give up two ones and a
four to get him and now
ramsay's got all the leverage and the
rams are looking at the very real
possibility
of giving up two ones and a four for a
guy that they have for a year and a half
which is unthinkable and would be
unforgivable if it happened so now
here are the seahawks with a guy who
won't be disgruntled on the way through
the door in seattle but he has a history
of being disgruntled he's got a history
of acting out and he's got a history of
speaking out
and if he has a big year this year and
they don't offer him the kind of money
he's looking for and i've seen upwards
of 20 million a year when the
safety market chris is currently below
15 million right if jamal adams gets it
in his head that he's worth 20 million a
year if it's that
julio jones dynamic that we saw in
atlanta a couple of years ago
where you say oh the quarterback's
making 35 million a year i'm at least
worth half that
i'm worth more than half that on the
defense i'm the russell wilson of the
defense
then the next thing you know a year from
now or less than that
you've got jamal adams who's got all the
leverage because they've already made
the investment with the draft picks
if he decides he's going to start
treating the seahawks the way he treated
the jets
then the whole thing blows up in their
face yeah you're right i mean you know i
it is definitely risky there's no doubt
about that
now you know seattle's ultimate has the
ultimate confidence in their culture
and the environment and just the
enthusiasm that's in that building on a
day-to-day basis i mean anybody i've
ever talked to that's all they ever
that's all they ever say i know until
they have to run off half the team
because they're sick of dealing with the
guys well no doubt about it
until they until they reach their wits
end it's all great well you're right but
they're not scared of it that's that's
what we know they're not scared of
personalities but you're right they're
gonna at some point
have to deal with this but you know pay
the pied piper here
with jamal adams i mean hey 20 million a
year
that you know when i hear that right now
i go that's a little crazy like you said
nobody's making 15.
let's just start at 18. you know 17 okay
let's not just blow the market out of
the water here but either way
yes that day is going to come i do think
seattle realizes of course how special
the football player is
and how important that position is to
make their defense successful
and let me just throw this into it too
because this is worthwhile
my father always points this out to me
with jamal adams
and i think it's a real point because
yes he wants his money and we all sit
here and you know
oh gosh you're making good money and i
get it you know
yes athletes are spoiled a little bit
but this is their great
talent in life and they got to
capitalize jamal adams father george
adams played running back for the new
york giants
my dad would tell you that he was going
to be a superstar
that he thought oh my gosh we might have
one of the best running backs in
football
well he played one season going into
training camp as second year
he had the bo jackson injury right his
hip dislocated he tore the labrum around
his hip
never really got to make any money do
anything in his whole career i really
think that is in jamal adams
his brain how could it not be when that
happened to his father
so because of that i think he's you know
kind of
driven the stake into the ground a
little bit and wants to be paid now this
will cool him off for a little bit but
you're right at some point he's gonna go
okay somebody pay me my freaking money
i'm one of the best defensive players in
football and hopefully seattle's smart
and does that some point during this
season
i want to flip over to the jets angle
chris before i do that though
i have an idea of one last point as it
relates to the seahawks right and jamal
adams and paying jamal adams
and i am going to tell everyone check
out p-f-t-o-t
on peacock youtube wherever
because we're gonna we have a we have a
lead topic for pftot we'll get to that
after the show but there's too many
other things to get to
than to have me babble on and on for
possibly 10 minutes about this theory
that just popped into my head while we
were talking about this all right
from the jets perspective as we've
already said it's an offer you can't
refuse
two first-round picks even if they're
going to be low a third round pick a
safety to replace jamal adams and you
give up a four along with adams in 2022.
you can't say no to that
especially when you have a guy who
does not want to be there and a guy who
has
just gone scorched earth now here's the
thing
scorched earth the trait the trade was
in the works
before jamal adams decided to tweet
in disapproving fashion regarding the
allegations made last week
against jet's owner woody johnson in his
capacity as u.s ambassador
to great britain the trade was in the
works when jamal adams decided to go on
the record with fellow founding member
of the adam gase hater club manish meta
and the two of them just
unloaded on gays the deal was already in
the works
this wasn't the last domino that got the
deal done
that got the jets to relent this wasn't
the trigger
to make the deal happen out of thin air
the deal was already happening i'm told
that the reason it happened saturday is
because on friday that's when everything
crystallized as to what the salary cap
will be this year
and next year and that's when everyone
was satisfied
we can do this deal and move forward had
nothing to do with jamal adams said
so the end result is chris all that
stuff jamal adams did last week
it was gratuitous yeah and if anything
it potentially could have blown it up
what if the seahawks had
yeah and the seahawks could have
squeezed the jets on this and they said
well you know we were going to give you
two twos and a
three and bradley mcdougall before
friday but
now that your guy is going crazy here
and
going all in on adam gase and you guys
have an untenable situation
we're not gonna we're not so inclined to
give you all that stuff now we're gonna
peel back that third round pick we're
gonna
maybe make that first round pick in 2022
a second round pick
what could the jets have done so jamal
adams could have jeopardized the
trade with that desire to take a shot at
adam gase last weekend
yeah um i mean when you hear that you
just go well yeah what the hell are you
thinking jamal adams
why would you do that why would you risk
it why would you let pete
carroll and john schneider who are
sitting there and you obviously know
there's there's action behind the scenes
as far as your agent the jets
and the seattle seahawks why would you
even put in their you know
in their brains at all that like man
this guy is he a jerk
or you know is he a bad guy like you
know and especially because they know
they know he knows that this trade
talk's going down and he's still doing
these type of things
so yeah i did not like that i'm not
gonna lie here i mean
as much as i like jamal adams and the
way he plays football and i've been
around jamal a lot of times
a few times he's a fun guy he really is
he's intense
he's intense in real life too but you
know i don't like the shots at adam gase
on the way out the door you know when
you know you want out the door you're
trying to get out the door you're doing
anything you can to do that
you know adam gase for whatever reason
people like to pile on him at times and
i don't understand that either
and you know manish meta i mean you know
who you know i mean don't even get me
started on that subject either
i mean yeah i mean this is this is what
is equivalent but it's not cool
in school remember remember in school
when the teacher
forgot to assign homework right and
you're always thinking hey is she going
to remember
before we go out the door on friday
afternoon jamal adams was the guy who
stood in the doorway
and made fun of the teacher for not
assigning homework on the way out the
door that
i mean he jeopardized this deal that
hasn't come out yet but
common sense tells me you jeopardize
that deal because if you're dealing with
another team
and maybe john schneider decided not to
take advantage of this but he could have
and you could argue if you're a seahawks
fan he should have you put the screws to
the jets
and you say to them you you've got a
you've got a mess here
we we will not do this deal on these
terms not now circumstances have changed
because jamal ran
ran off his mouth and it was it was dumb
he could have potentially blown the
whole
thing up and found himself stuck with
the jets
or not going to the seahawks a team
where he presumably will be happy
because it's going to be a much better
team than the jets have been during his
career well yeah i mean the thing i
think about too is
i mean maybe did you know did jamal
adams
as the conversations were going down did
he think they were
the jets were trying to drive too hard
of a bargain or something like that
and within that was he trying to lower
his price to help seattle out that way i
mean those are things that people didn't
i know it didn't you're right here's
here's my theory yeah my theory is
he wasn't fully informed of what was
going on because
i the the you know whether it's agents
or
joe douglas the gm of the jets or
anybody else i mean if jamal adams has
that information who knows what he's
going to do with that information yeah
okay
maybe that information gets out
prematurely right so he didn't know how
far down the road the conversation was
maybe right i hear you maybe i hear it
baby
yeah well hey either way you know the
jets got rid of them
it was an issue you know obviously and
you know the jets anyways they're a team
that this is a good move for them
yeah i mean it's never easy to trade
away a great player like jamal adams
but the jets come on jets fans know this
everybody knows this
they're not one guy away right now
they're a
whole plethora of guys away still i mean
they're really they're almost back in
rebuild mode uh
and adam gase has got a unbelievable gm
there behind him now finally and joe
douglas who
i mean killed it in free agency i
thought killed it in the draft he's
given us every inkling so far that
he'll know what to do with it you know
as far as these draft picks when they
when they come about
and maybe they can build something here
substantial but i didn't look at the
jets as going
ooh you know this is the year
this is the year they're going to go to
the playoffs no i still look at them as
a team to go
no they're two years away and and really
probably three years away from really
being like
okay we're a team that's one of the
better teams in afc or at least getting
in that conversation
but that's hardly ideal when you've got
a rookie quarterback i know
i'm not a rookie quarterback but a
quarterback on his rookie contract this
is the time to load the cannon and go
for it before you have to pay
the quarterback that it may be that they
are starting to emerge and have it all
fall together
just as they have to make a decision on
sam darnold and
i i i think it's way too early to say
that the jets have committed to making a
major investment in sam darnold on a
second contract i mean he could be
gone a year from now too but you know
the jets
uh did what they had to do here
and if you'd have told me on friday when
we were digesting the comments from
jamal adams
about adam gase and the wreckage of that
potentially and how hard it would be to
trade and how awkward it's going to be
when adam shows up this week because he
made it clear he was going to show up
the idea of getting two first-round
picks plus
for jamal adams would have been
incomprehensible so yes this is a deal
the jets had to do
and they needed to make a break from
that that situation because it just
wasn't working regardless of who's at
fault
it wasn't working and their first round
picks have not been working
their first round picks from 2013 to
2017 are all
gone and now that's all pr pre joe
douglas
and pre-adam gase but they're all gone i
mean they have done a poor job the john
itzik and mike mckagne regimes were
abject failures
yeah for the new york jets and now
they're just trying to rebuild it yeah
and they're going to rebuild it
with a pair of first-round picks in 2021
and a pair of first round picks in 2022
and who knows maybe if they play their
cards right it's going to be 2 000 all
over again where they end up with four
first round picks in one draft
not that those four first round picks
turned into hall of famers but still the
more shots you get the more lottery
tickets you have
the better the chance that you have it
at having a transformational draft that
turns you into a
year-in and year-out contender yeah no i
think that's exactly right and you know
there is some things there we know sam
darnold's there
uh and you know listen like pete
demelitis are
are one of our producers here he goes
are the jets wasting the rookie contract
window of uh
of sam darnold yeah they are they're
wasting it but
you know there's nothing they can do the
team was built badly around them they
haven't put a lot of talent around them
you know adam gase got handed over a
piece of crap i don't know what else
somebody
expects i mean like what what does
people think adam gates was handed here
in new york with this football team
yeah offensive line crappy you know wide
receivers okay
one's injured the one you know one guy
had some off the field issue and had
talent okay they get rid of him in free
agency defense
i mean there's nothing to talk about on
defense jamal adams is the only guy to
talk about really
yeah we got some hopeful guys and quinn
and williams okay here we go
what else is on the team right now i
mean that's it
so joe douglas has gone back to square
one and i think him
and joe douglas coming from philly and
baltimore he knows how to build a
football
team and adam gase this ain't his first
rodeo too
i still have faith in this group here
that they're going to get this right
but yeah you already said it the prior
regimes
left this franchise in a crappy place
you're not going gonna fix it in one or
two
years to where it is right now there's
nothing to talk about on that team
from the prior regime so they're
starting from scratch we'll see where it
goes this is a good start with some of
these assets they got from this trade
one name you did not mention was le'veon
bell oh yeah and
here's the thing here's the thing mike
mckagan the last gm he got grifted to a
certain extent by bell's agent because
he was led to believe that the ravens
were legitimate players
for le'veon bell at her about the same
financial
range that the jets landed which was
much higher than whatever the next
offers would have been remember the
49ers oh i know
if it would have been like 5 million a
year less in total salary
but the thing is and this is something
that i i don't think gets mentioned
enough
a high-end running back is useless to a
team that does not have an
offense around him the high-end running
back is the last piece not the first
piece
the first piece is the offensive line
the second piece is the quarterback
the third piece is the pass catchers
once you have the threat
of a run of a passing game then you go
all in with a running back that is going
to make a huge difference but here's
reality if you have all that other stuff
you don't need to pay a ton of money for
a running back because any running back
you plug in there is going to do pretty
damn well because you've got the passing
game
to keep the defense off balance but
le'veon bell it was a mistake and
and in hindsight it was regardless of
his talent it's a mistake
to build from the outside in you got to
build your offense from the inside
and these are some of the things that
the jets are now trying to deal with
on the fly as they transform this team
into
something other than what it's been
chris yeah no you're exactly right and i
mean mike that's
it's like spot on i mean you don't start
there
you don't you don't give a guy a chance
i don't care if they had le'veon bell we
brought barry sanders jim brown back
they're not going anywhere with that
offensive line and what they had
blocking in front of them last year
so yeah you haven't you know they
haven't even give le'veon bell enough
support to really show what he can
really do
now hopefully this is the year you know
hopefully he can show it
uh but but you're right there's been
some failures
and the proper way to build a football
team here in new york i
and again i think joe douglas is the guy
that's gonna do it um but
yeah they're not one player away one
step away and you know just as we know
le'veon bell i don't think he's the
happiest that jamal adams tried to get
out of town either are we going to get
into that now are we going to do that
later
uh well i mean let's let's we can let's
touch on it briefly now
some twitter back and forth between
le'veon bell and jamal adams
uh le'veon bell did not like the fact
that adams wanted out because apparently
jamal adams one of the key voices in
getting le'veon bell
to sign on with the jets in 2019 jamal
adams
saying as little as he ever does noted
you week 14. le'veon bell
kind of interpreting that as a potential
threat i don't know that it's a threat
it's a reality the two teams get
together in seattle december 13
under the current schedule and it'll be
interesting to see what happens when
le'veon bell and jamal adams encounter
each other on the football field
but uh uh look this is what happens
when you have not only a guy who all of
a sudden wants out but a guy who is so
committed to getting out that it does do
damage like you know just if you want
out that's fine
but don't don't create a mess
for the rest of us that's right the
comments on
friday especially if tomorrow adam's had
any inkling he's getting out
it's gratuitous and it's unfair to his
former teammates because now they have
to clean up the mess
that's right that jamal adam's made by
deciding to go scorched earth on the
headcount yeah
that's really the big issue there i mean
yeah obviously le'veon bell
bell feels a little burned by the fact
that jamal adams recruited him there
probably pounded on the table
told jets guys to get le'veon bell there
and then he wants out
like yeah but you're right that's the
point is yeah he's made a mess
and now like frank gore has to answer
questions over the weekend about adam
gase and the jets and the organization
and it's something he has nothing to do
with and it's going to go in right into
training camp and then
yes this is going to become a story you
know because
of course this is everyone's latching on
to this up here and i don't think it's
right
you know and i don't i don't think the
jumping on the adam gase thing that's
the part i just don't understand right
now
and we're all going to take the word of
a guy who we know didn't want to be here
and was doing everything he could get
out now we're going to like
make him the jump off point to be like
oh yeah he's right
no i mean he did he was doing whatever
he could to get the hell out of here
had nothing to do really with adam gays
he was just making sure he was gonna
push a button every other day
to make sure it pissed the jets off to
maybe he could get out
and and get to where he wanted so that's
all there is to that
and i just i don't want to see it become
a thing here or a story as we go on
on the way to our first break of the day
here's jamal adams tweet the message to
the seahawks organization and fans
you have a man on a mission a man all in
on winning a super bowl being the best
leader and teammate he can be
and a man who will give everything he
has to the city of seattle
and to the twelves across the world
thank you for believing in me and
i believe in that 100 the question is
what happens if and when
jamal adams isn't happy with his
contract with the scheme
with the offense with the coaching staff
with anything else because he's proven
in his three years in the nfl
and this goes back to todd balls when he
doesn't like something
he says so and the seahawks are going to
have to deal with that
the first time there's something jamal
adams doesn't like
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports